we've learned about matrix addition
matrix subtraction matrix multiplication
so you might be wondering is is there
the equivalent of matrix division and
before we get into that we'll let me
introduce some concepts to you and then
we'll see that there is something that
maybe isn't exactly division but it's
analogous to it so before we introduce
that let's i'm going to introduce you to
the concept of an identity matrix
so an identity matrix is a matrix and
i'll denote that
by capital i
when i multiply it times another matrix
times another matrix
actually i don't know if i should write
that dot there but anyway when i
multiply it times another matrix i get
that other matrix or when i multiply
that matrix times the identity matrix
i get the matrix again
and it's important to realize in in when
we're doing matrix multiplication that
direction matters so it's actually this
is i've actually given you some
information here that
you know we can't just assume when we
were doing regular multiplication that
you know a times b is always equal to b
times a it's important when we're doing
matrix multiplication to kind of confirm
that it matters what direction you do
the multiplication in
but anyway and actually i just want to
make sure this this works both ways only
if we're dealing with um
only if we're dealing with square
matrices it can work in one direction or
another if if this matrix is non-square
but it won't work in both and you can
think about that
just in terms of how we learned matrix
multiplication why that happens but
anyway i've defined this matrix now what
does this matrix actually look like it's
actually pretty simple
if we have a 2 by 2 matrix the identity
matrix is one zero zero one
if you want three by three it's one zero
zero zero one zero zero zero one i think
you see the pattern if you want a four
by four the identity matrix is
one zero zero zero zero one zero zero
zero zero one zero zero zero zero one so
you can see all the identity matrix is
for a given dimension i mean we could
extend this to an n by n matrix is you
just have ones along this top left to
bottom right diagonals and everything
else is a zero
so i've told you that let's prove that
it actually works so let's take this
matrix and multiply it times another
matrix and confirm that that matrix
doesn't change so if we take
1 0 0 1
and let's multiply it times let's do a
general matrix
just so you see that this works for all
numbers a b
c d
so what does that equal
1 times so we're going to multiply this
row times this column
1 times a plus 0 times c is a and that
row times this column 1 times b plus 0
times d that's b
then this row times this column 0 times
a plus 1 times c is c
and then finally this row times this
column zero times b plus one times d
well that's just d
there you have it and it might be a fun
exercise to try it the other way around
as well and i think if and actually it's
even better exercise to try this with a
three by three and you'll see it all
works out and and a good exercise for
you is to kind of think about why it
works and if you think about it because
you're getting your row information from
here and your column information from
here
and essentially anytime you're
multiplying let's say this vector
times this vector
you're multiplying the corresponding
terms and then adding them right
so if you have a 1 and a 0 the 0 is
going to cancel out anything but the
first term in this column vector so
that's why you're just left with a and
that's why it's going to cancel out
everything but the first term in this
column vector and that's why you're left
with just b and similarly this will
cancel out everything but the second
term so that's why you're left with just
c there
right this times this you're just left
with c this times this you're just left
with d and that same thing applies when
you go to three by three or n by n
vectors
so that's interesting you have the the
identity vector now if we wanted to
complete our analogy so let's think
about it we know in regular mathematics
if i have you know 1 times a
i get a
and we also know that
1 over a
times a this is just regular math this
has nothing to do with matrices is equal
to 1
right so and you know we call this the
inverse of a and that's also the same
thing as dividing by the number a right
so is there a matrix analogy is there a
matrix and let me switch colors because
i've used this green a little bit too
much is there a matrix
where if i have the matrix a
and i multiply it by
this matrix and i'll call that the
inverse of a is there a matrix where i
am left with not the number one but i'm
left with kind of the one equivalent in
the matrix world where i'm left with the
identity matrix
and it would be extra nice if i could
actually switch this multiplication
around
so a
time times a inverse
should also be equal to the identity
matrix and if you think about it if both
of these things are true then they're
actually not only is a inverse the
inverse of a but a is also the inverse
of a inverse so they're each other's
inverses that's the only that's all i
meant to say
and it turns out there is such a matrix
it's called the inverse of a as i've
said three times already and i will now
show you how to calculate it
so let's do that
and we'll see calculating it for two by
two is fairly straightforward although
you might see think it's a little um
mysterious as to how people came up with
the with the the the mechanics of it or
the algorithm for it uh three by three
becomes a little hairy four by four will
take you all day five by five you know
you're you're almost definitely going to
do a careless mistake if you did a did
the inverse of a 5x5 matrix and that's
better left to to a computer but anyway
how do we calculate the matrix so let's
do that and then we'll confirm that it
really is the inverse
so if i have a matrix a
if i have a matrix a
and that is let's just say a
b
c
d
and i want to calculate this inverse
it's inverses actually
and this is going to seem like voodoo
and in future videos i will give you a
little bit more intuition for why this
works i'll actually show you how this
came about but for now it's almost
better just to memorize the steps
just so you have the confidence that you
know that you can calculate an inverse
it's equal to 1 over
this number times this a times d
minus b times c
a
d
minus b c
and this quantity down here a d minus b
we'll we'll learn soon has a special
well actually we don't have to learn it
soon that's called the determinant of
the matrix a
and we're going to multiply that and so
this is just a number right this is just
a scalar quantity and we're going to
multiply that by
you switch the a and the d you switch
the top left and the bottom right so
you're left with d
and a
and you make these two you make the
bottom left and the top right you make
them negative
so minus c
and minus b
and the determinant and once again this
is something that you're just going to
have to take a little bit on faith right
now in future videos i promise to give
you more tuition it's actually kind of
sophisticated to learn what the
determinant is and if you're doing this
in your high school class
you kind of just have to know how to
calculate it although i don't like
telling you that
so what is this so this is the this is
also called the determinant of and you
might see on an exam you know figure out
the determinant of a so that let me just
tell you that and that's donated by a
and kind of absolute value signs and
that's equal to
ad
minus bc so another way of saying this
this could be 1 over the determinant so
you could write a inverse is equal to 1
over the determinant
of a
times d minus b
minus c
a
anyway you look at it but let's let's
apply this to a real problem and you'll
see that it's actually not so bad
so let's say that i have a matrix let's
pick change letters just so you know it
doesn't always have to be an a let's say
i have a matrix b
and the matrix b is
three
i'm just going to pick random numbers
minus
four
two
minus 5.
let's calculate b inverse
so b
inverse is going to be equal 1 over the
determinant of b what's the determinant
it's 3 times -5
minus two times minus four so three
times minus five is minus fifteen
minus two times minus four two times
minus four is minus eight we're gonna
subtract that so it's plus eight
plus 8
and we're going to multiply that
times
multiply that times
what
well we switch these two terms so it's
minus five
and three and we just make these two
terms negative
minus two
and four right four is minus four so now
it becomes four
and let's see if we can simplify this a
little bit so b
inverse is equal to it's minus 15 plus
eight that's minus
seven so this is minus one seventh
so the determinant of b we could you
know we could write b's determinant is
equal to minus
that's minus
1 7
times
minus 5
4
minus 2
3
which is equal to this is just a scalar
this is just a number so we multiply
times each of the elements so that is
equal to
minus minus plus so it's 5 7
5 7
minus 4 7
see positive 2 7
two sevenths
and then minus three sevenths
minus three sevenths
it's a little hairy we ended up with
fractions in here and things but let's
confirm that this really is the inverse
of the matrix b let's multiply them out
so before i do that i should create some
space
let me create some space here
i don't even need this anymore
there you go okay so let's confirm
that
that times
this or this times that is really equal
to the identity matrix so let's do that
so
let me switch colors so b inverse is
5 over 7 if i haven't made any careless
mistakes
minus 4 over 7
2
over 7
minus 3 over 7.
that's b inverse and let me multiply
that by b
3
minus 4
2
minus 5.
now this is going to be the product
matrix
i need some space to do my calculations
so let's see first i'm going to take
this let me take switch colors i'm going
to take this row
times this column
so 5 7
times 3
is what 15 over 7
15 over 7
ti
plus minus 4 7 times
2. so minus 4 7 times 2 is
it's minus
let me make sure that's right 5 times 3
is 15 over 7
minus 4 oh yeah right 4 times 2 so minus
8 over 7
minus 8 over 7.
now we're going to multiply this row
times this column so 5 times -4 is
minus 20 over 7
so minus 20
over 7
plus
minus
4
right so minus 4
7 times -5
that is plus 20 over 7
plus 20 over 7.
my my brain is starting to slow down
having to do matrix multiplications with
fractions with negative numbers but this
is a good exercise for for multiple
parts of the brain but anyway so let's
go down to this term so now we're going
to multiply
we're going to multiply this row
times this column so 2 7 times 3 is
6 7
plus
minus 3 7 times 2 so that's minus 6 7
one term left home stretch 2 7 times
minus 4 is minus 8 7
minus 8 7 right 2 7 times 4 is minus 8 7
plus
minus 3 7 times minus 5. so those
negatives cancel out and we're left with
plus
15 over 7
15 over 7. and if we simplify what do we
get
15
7 minus 8 7 is 7 7 well that's just 1.
this is zero clearly
this is zero six seven's minus six
sevens is zero
and then minus eight sevenths plus
fifteen sevenths that's seven sevenths
that's one again and there you have it
we have actually managed to inverse this
matrix and actually as you see it was
actually harder to prove that it was the
inverse by multiplying it just because
you do all this this this fraction and
negative number math
but hopefully that that satisfies you
and you could try it the other way
around to confirm that if you multiply
the other way you would also get the
identity matrix but anyway that is how
you calculate the inverse of a two by
two and as we'll see in the next video
calculating by uh the inverse of a three
by three matrix is even more fun see you
soon